foreign
I'm gonna stop early just somebody take
my corner
hey get back
let's chill chill chill chill chill I'm
here
get that though
chase him
make the milk and cloth that's fine
that's fine just get us through
that's insane that's a still I ain't
gonna lie that's a stew foreign
[ __ ]
Jordy jump that
middle I ain't gonna lie we [ __ ]
missed a hundred steals bro come on
knock down
let's go let's go 14 seconds
let's let's
show that show that jump still that
oh wow
yo he [ __ ] made that
quick quick quick get an inbox too
everybody everybody get a man everybody
get a man
yeah
oh Brandon Brandon we might have to run
to play
remember to run to play
what you mean the same thing right
oh come on put them on we might have to
run a plate no no [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
Brandon uh
go for nah [ __ ] that go for the game go
for the game I don't care if we get that
unless you yo I got badge I could take a
fake which I want me to do
which I'm gonna do
what you told me to do not bringing the
shoes my brain is shooting all right all
right I'm gonna come back door I'm gonna
cut back door Brandon you catch that
shot I'm gonna cut back door who's
inbounder who's inbounded
we got one more time out okay okay uh
give it to me back to it Brandon go uh
run top of the key when you go ready
Brian Jesus Christ
Brian
would he [ __ ] himself
Brandon go Corner go like go where I'm
at go where I'm at
ready one two three go
no way
he's the best I've ever seen [ __ ]
best I've ever seen what the [ __ ] man
the best I've ever seen
stop calling my [ __ ] guy Brandon
[ __ ] out of here